you
yeah everyone is 21 plus that's this is
almost almost like an elite bullet arena
for at least the top eight here the
elite bullet arenas are 2200 and above
hello prawn sac all right ooh that one
caught me off guard here here we go Jona
VK we have played many times as you can
see I missed that they moved here
now we're gonna move forward keep this a
g4 square guarded
yeah let's get a flight Square in right
now on a different like this that's a
strong piece so let's get rid of them
Queen trade like my queen might be close
to trapped
yeah like pawn push and then rook a3 oh
maybe still they had that they okay well
I don't like how implying this I'm gonna
try to eliminate my
dark-squared bishop and i think they're
close to being successful with that well
I have to cover my dark square somehow
now
oh really come on I don't want to draw
don't you dare go back there thank you
now that said I probably should have now
I want the draw now maybe I don't get
the job uncle where's my time where's my
time that's another very Oh No oh yeah
I'm toast now like a trade down like a
machine like a machine
mmm-hmm slippery pond
not even close Oh fact it's tournament
ah man what did I allow
my back my bishop he was such a bad man
my bishop was such a bad man I can't let
that ever happen my bishop ever again
not in this tournament
I'm sorry bishop my LightSquared bishop
Oh my opponent didn't move this is elite
elite rating my opponent is stunned by
Queen c7 maybe uh-hmm
that's a pawn maybe connection issue
they were thinking that one through ah
yeah you know what happened in that game
yes I lost but what was what was my
downfall there I didn't I didn't get the
necessary
that's a Queenie I didn't get the
necessary Queen side play got locked
down and my queen was running scared and
was my opponent doing I don't know
yeah they locked down the Queen side and
then that f5 move came in so fast all
right that one's over with we got a W in
round two there are 82 players in this
one let's see what kind of herring again
next
who's in first coming after you China
trying to get him back all right
we could go we could do some kind of
reversed fishing pole yeah we could try
for though these kind of tricks why nots
let's cover this square and that's why I
want the bishop here all right so can't
feel too good
let's get on this long diagonal huh
gotta break up that pawn duo somehow
yeah we're gonna hop in right now I want
to open his eyes yeah good move man
good move I'm on the rook all right okay
think I had anything I'm here Oh Queen
here now no not right now
I want to deflect let's take with the
bishop
I want Queen c3 no I don't want to trade
we're gonna try some checks here it's
not really working to have anything
fancy you take me cuz I have me yes
doctor tournament that it wasn't force
they had to a block rook f6 Queen f6
probably best they're not going into a
pin all right we're gonna line up some
tricks on the Kings side maybe like a
how ok how you hop into that you
Foursquare that's how you do it
alrighty let's keep okay well I think
I'm ready to lose some material here if
I don't make that kind of capture Queen
takes this night oh it's my move
ok oh no no let's take this guy alright
I'm gonna just try and keep it simple
it's distracted a little bit there
there's a queen trade okay it's a dog
barking outside alright so a strong King
position
these guys pushing a little bit now
let's go on this end first
now we'll go with this this one pun
restricts too though they could break
that up hmm let's go here come back over
I don't want to draw no drawers no
drawers step up we're making forward
progress
I'm gonna track that pond down gave me
the pawn Oh Oh even on the clock there
we go
making some serious headway there we go
trades cut off the king get the rook
where's the mate
where is the mate
I'm out there huh they're down on time
can you guys hear that dog in the
background
sneaky dog what is it doing outside
anyhow it's freezing out
alright I'm in 11th who care who cares
about the diamond this is more important
this is my I see a DJ chess dog in that
in the tournament maybe that's his dog
alright
bullet Jeff's clearly more important
than a dog's health right it's not true
I love dogs I love dogs take care of
them
everyone's here for that advise everyone
right now is tuned in just to hear me
talk about dogs health
all right we don't want the night
posting up here and my bishop looks
silly on c6 do I not realize that the
rook is opposite my king you should okay
there wasn't made here
look at these sneaky tactics
unbelievably sneaky let me see if I got
lined up some sneaky stuff against my
favorite square careful got a knight and
the pond Kings running for his life he's
still running he's still running he's
still running
that's me back to tournament I'm in
fifth I got 12 pointing a time par for
T's and first it's got five games in
well so do i all right let's see Game
six did we got well he's playing his
sixth already right here a hundred and
two in this one and as 1488 already oh
come on who plays knight c6 I should
have captured that night
no no no no no not that one either
Bishop here castle gonna go for
discovery I'm not afraid of that
maybe I am if I wasn't afraid of that
why did I play King h1 throw down the H
font here maybe we give made on the H
file Bishop wants to do something yes
it's doing something picking up a free
piece and now we push the F pawn throw a
knight in deaf for Queen takes pawn me
it's not leading to me on a break into
these light squares last then I move
about I have a boatload of material okay
they resigned back to tournament I got
sixteen all right Jonah BK is in first
the guy that gave me a beating in Game
one I'm getting berserk this guy runs
like the wind blows
Oh sneaky get my knight back in the ball
game this is a pre moving machine to be
careful about saying that yeah I don't
really mean that
we tried not like iPhone it's cheating
type machine just super fast can I win
that pond not quiet we're gonna stay
here I'm doing a very good job at Oh
snuck that one in there well hmm
sneaky
sneaky sneaky sneaky
hmm man
trying to time Bernama it didn't work I
got 18 they were a fire extinguisher ah
man okay I should have played position
instead of time I was staring at a clock
the whole game and wondering why their
flag wasn't falling play chess man don't
allow their little strategy to work like
that all right
we're gonna try to pick up the ape on
their right they defend in that I want
the light square bishop Soph let's stop
you for an f3 I have that for let's give
another night into e4
hop in light squares that's a tough
night to work around I guess here I want
to sneak over it's like the h5 square
ah that's the last square for my night
now I could go here no he's not going
anywhere I'll go here this pawn is now
connected and passed but I didn't want
fast entry along the C file I don't know
what I'm doing we're gonna try for this
sacrifice sacrifice against g3 and try
for a pawn push all right we'll try it
feel like I'm playing very slow very
slow
I have b5 hmm let's give a check not
getting made at em I just want to get
one rook off he's playing for time on
that one again I got to stop that I'm in
second somehow these good these these
big guys took some hits here yep and
Jonah who did he lose to I'm gettin
berserk again all right come on play the
position man I was tempted play Bishop
h6 there what no no no no no slow down
slow down man Wow all right
come on you can do it I was almost ready
to drop the house there oh okay let's
hang on it up hon let's push here and
then go here
easy does it what am i doing
hmm all right we're gonna anchor the
night in there look for mate I have to
sacrifice this was the best technique
ever what I did run run
take a pond take this one run there keep
running they resigned yes back to
tournament land to strike Knight f3 and
we're gonna go so this is the pack
leader if you're wondering we're both in
that 22 I'm gonna shut it down gonna
break it up let's try a different
structure I don't think it's good what
we're gonna give it a go 90 for mix it
up just a hair maybe they give me the a
file gotta defend that upon ninth seed
three soon mend my structure let's get
rid of that Bishop he's too strong okay
why was there hesitation here I'm just
dropping that night no good I don't know
not playing this well again
I got to get rid of one of the rooks at
least I have that pun to I am up mmm a
little bit scary just a little bit when
I keep that night under control yes okay
I think I have a wall formed with my
pond and night my king is having fun
working into the light are the light
squares do I know it squares yes
dark square invasion love it
look at that wall it's amazing down on
time they couldn't break down the wall
that was a bad game don't look at that
one 26 23 22 I'm in front
123 in this one less than 8
oh look at this monster puppy lover 420
already oh I was ready to fall for that
little mega one who knows what I'm
talking about
this guy's throne mate and ones at me
left and right
left and right careful careful now
all right let's get I'm gonna get hurt
over here I might get hurt
it's a very weakening move I know we're
gonna do it still I think I can I think
I can I have no idea what that mounts
about maybe I do
oh I didn't see that move somehow let's
go here I want to get on the long
diagonal
I have some serious dark square
weaknesses just like my opponent did in
the last game hmm I could get hurt
really easy that nights not gonna go
anywhere I'm gonna try to get in here
oof not see that move I'm floundering
I'm definitely floundering oh look at my
time I should resign this high wasted
too much time they had me under a lot of
fire yeah like I said in the game that I
won previous to that I had dark square
control my opponent had darks where
control as soon as I played f5
well it's gonna make for an interesting
finish 26 26 25 24 the top five none of
us have fire let's see if I could get a
good streak in here with these last
three may need to berserk Yeah right he
never berserks
he's a chicken chicken oh I love that
that's a beautiful square beautiful
get out of there where's the Queen goin
oh she can't go anywhere she's trapped
back to tournament I love it I really
didn't realize that I didn't I didn't
see that actually I was covering all the
squares for 40 left 129 in this one
let's see how it ends cats are awesome
I got a two-point lead all righty
Oh going right after my throat what did
I do to deserve this
you're gonna go on castled now that's
what you get
we're gonna try 4 B 5 B 4 B 5 B 4 hmm
I'm not prepared to have the a file
opened up let's try that
pick up the knight push here oh you
sneaky got you I guess this is the way
to save both of those pieces discovery
checks discovered attacks let's get a
trade in there on the Queen I have a
knight check here
captured not quite uh I don't like I'm
playing this working in two pins and
everything I want to break this down
here mm-hmm let's get rid of this no oh
okay
hang on though they're down a time hang
on they're down on time alex is right on
my heels
I got a one-point lead he's in a game
he's in a game that he berserk hang on
chest night 2001 xanbot oh one more game
for sure has to has to get in there all
right we're gonna think eddo
you're gonna go clean side okay let's
castle
they're setting up a minority they're
being clever about it clever Bishop on
d6 powerhouse that's a new one I gotta
use that term lure powerhouse
the people they move where's that night
going
he's a dancing machine watch out for
pins playing with the h-file now hang on
Bishop you're cooked with check still
going hunting looking for some tricky
stuff Bishop here does that mean
it's made I love it back to tournament
37 oh I'm back three he's in a game pub
but he has to play against puppy lover
come on puppy lover 420 knock him out I
have to get one more game in with the
minute 15 come on
pair me up man all right now if I went
if I'm in a better position with this
one of my opponent resign or what I get
known a fried dough in a fry
well this is this is a very very good
position I thought I don't like how I
played it just then it's gonna hop in
there no why would why didn't the bishop
jump in there
I don't know
37 seconds not looking good
ah 25 mm-hmm yeah 17 seconds I'm
floundering I don't know what to do
11 seconds it's not happening
five seconds three seconds I need to
just play regular chest now ooh okay
this is gonna hurt mmm okay I'm in
trouble I am in trouble 24 seconds I
have a fork if
comes over here oh I am such a big
trouble I didn't see that at all
getting mated ah I'm in such big trouble
I'm getting mated oh I could take the
rook I'm slipping away
slippery King there aren't any time they
have time I can't move I have to move
upon aha Exeter Apple slipped away uh
okay
37 34 30 28 28 mm 137 in that one
let's have a look at page two man that
was that was an interesting end three
the Hebrew Sark all of them no not quite
there we go that was a fun one I think
I'm gonna do another these are fun see
the rest of the pages
almost there yeah if I was trying to win
that last one I shouldn't have gone for
such an early Queen trade I have to kick
that habit and now those must-win
situations already to the 136 of you
good games all fun as always
you
[Music]